hello welcome to this video playing
crypto chess and played him once and
lost ok don't remember that so one of
the main lines of the Italian game oh
it's a bit unsure when to go 45 and when
went when not to do that must be
entirely honest down five years they
don't move hey that's kind of really be
bad but I'm always unsure so I'm just
playing it in a in a cautious way with
bishop you six this can never be bad
really ok just castles very yeah playing
in a very simple manner Kim so grab this
and just castle is that though is that a
case of the wrong look hmm yet also
taking comes into consideration takes
takes d5 you have 94 let's do that it's
an interesting interesting way to play
you cannot take the night and I think
that should be a pretty decent caught a
pretty decent position k I was thinking
98 96 but of course here I can't eat
first and then go f6 that I mean as bone
structure is pretty awful so it can't be
bad and is totally completely unfazed
just move move move ok boys gfive good
now such a belief so it's good 36
so maybe just Queenie several here at
most pressure on that bishop and now
enter him not quite sure that helps a
lot actually you can go Quincy three or
something like that quit d3 for that ok
quindi 3f Queenie forward or Quincy
three i can probably yeah yeah queenie
queenie for a bit what does it really do
don't know it also can hardly be bad I
think
come to f5 interesting yeah so this is a
d5 is a tech 97 that's probably Queen d7
coming
okay let's go for a simple move rookie
13 takes f5 should be okay for me
yeah what is he coming up with this
smooth interesting for Queen age form so
let's go here maybe on rights to this
Queen age for maybe rookie for young
before is good
maybe you can take play Bishop now
should be three okay it's not it's not
terrible for me or anything check
maybe just take it and let's take it it
sets a simple way to do it h5 not quite
sure that this ever helps some and now
just normal move here like this
yeah it's not the kind of move you want
to play hmm but how do I get anywhere
here that is not so easy actually
if i move the night ever is going 95 so
it's not it's not that simple him
surprising
ok i will try if I can get to the beep
on its you have to be cautious here king
of one Roxy tool don't have many squares
for the rook check time morning I have
to go back here which is not ideal
either
okay Wow and might has no squares well
that one which is not bad check so
40-something seconds night is well
positioned it covers all kinds of stuff
I don't know I just can just bring the
key to age for now I think it wasn't
that wasn't very tough what he tried
here with chief or at least that's what
I'm thinking at the moment the
confirmation in my night is completely
this is ideal really completely a deal
is that a good move I wonder I can go to
the six though it's ok and now oops come
on and then just bring bring the palms
up check check hmm that wasn't necessary
really ok I think I can do it 10 seconds
is check pretty much checkmate so young
my initial cake was that this should be
excellent and somehow and it wasn't that
clear at the computer also thinks I'm
substantially better but it wasn't easy
at all ok so this move engine gives this
as pretty strong for Bishop f5
then I can too mmm okay jack jump there
that's pretty good should be six is
probably stronger I thought that those
traits would help but chat which wasn't
so super clear okay the computer dis
prefer age 5 h 5 is the more care what
you call it principal to move not
getting rid of his double porn but i
thought that it should be easier to play
when the engine actually likes my plate
always get shined that kind of a pretty
clear advantage I could have taken now
instead of c6 already saw that a bit too
late and retakes and check yeah I think
that that end game is very good but
probably winning but the G for help yeah
you just basically a blonde at the
kingside him Adam was very helpful of
course yeah so on tough tough game to a
game with some interesting point CM
could have played you gave to lots of a
lot earlier ok well thanks for watching